these are dipping ducks or drinking
birds or whatever you like to call them
we made a film about them about six
years ago you can still watch that but
today I'd like to look at them in a bit
more detail and in particular we'd like
to use a thermal imaging camera but
first let's have a look at how they're
made as you can see when the felt heads
removed it's essentially just two glass
bulbs connected by a tube but it's
important to note the tube extends down
here and that the liquid inside is
something like dichloromethane a liquid
that evaporates easily
it's normally clear but colored here so
we can see it better now because the
liquid so volatile it means we have
quite a bit of vapour in this area and
importantly that vapour sealed here in
the upper chamber because as you can see
the tube down here is below the liquid
level now with the felt head on and
that's also important we wet the bird's
beak and water spreads through the felt
quickly encompassing the whole head this
water then starts evaporating cooling
the head it's a bit like the bird's
sweating to keep cool and that's when
things get interesting vapour in the
upper chamber starts to condense as it
cools and that means the pressure is
dropping something called the ideal gas
law would show with the temperature and
amount of gas falling the pressure Falls
to actually because of the gas liquid
phase transition this is more accurately
described by something called the
clausius clapeyron relation but that's
not quite so easy to pronounce you can
look into that more later anyway the
important thing is the higher pressure
down here where it's not cool starts
forcing liquid up the tube we can see it
and eventually due to the toys design
the bird becomes top-heavy and tips over
and now because of the clever placement
of the tube it's now above the liquid
level the seal between the head and the
tail is momentarily broken warm gas from
below can now force its way up the tube
and the liquid drains back down the
bottom importantly the pressure is
equalized and because the liquids
drained back down the toy tips back to
the upright position now this can go for
a long time but even longer if we have a
glass of water placed here because the
head stays wet for as long as we choose
now of course this isn't any kind of
perpetual motion heat is constantly
being extracted to keep the water
evaporating but speaking of heat let's
try this another way
instead of calling the head let's use a
hairdryer to warm the tail now first the
blow-dryer actually moves the toy into
its own position but that's to be
expected but here now instead of
lowering the pressure up top we're
increasing the temperature and amount of
gas in the bottom bulb thereby
increasing the pressure down below and
again liquid is forced up the neck and
sure enough this works too
[Music]
here's a comparison you can see the hot
ones almost too hot the next filled with
liquid almost all the time having done
this I then decided well maybe we should
try a few other things first using this
tea light as a source of heat under the
bird
[Music]
look how quickly the liquid Rises
and the bird stays sort of permanently
tipped trying to force it to the
vertical shows the problem there's just
too much heat a sort of endless loop of
liquid and hot gases being forced up the
tube by the high pressure below here you
can see just how much the lower sections
being heated so next I tried putting the
tea light here hoping for a gentler
application of heat to that bottom bulb
just a little bit of liquid creeping up
but never quite enough to tip the bird
and it was thermal-imaging that revealed
the problem you can see the tea light is
actually applying tremendous heat to the
top bulb the gas pressure up top is
increasing pressing down on the liquid
exactly what you don't want now okay
here's something else and I really
didn't know what to expect this time how
will the drinking bird work if you use
really hot or freezing cold water before
watching do you have any guesses well
after an initial dunk and letting the
water spread the cool-headed bird pretty
much works properly what you'd expect
but the hot-headed bird that's more
interesting the heat in the head must be
keeping the gas pressure in the top bulb
too high preventing the liquid from
being forced up the neck of course but
watch closely evaporative cooling starts
to kick in the temperature drops the
pressure drops the higher pressure below
now does its job
forcing liquid up the neck the bird
starts dipping as it over balances its
gradual and actually the mere act of
dipping puts more heat into the head
stalling the process you can see it but
eventually the back part of the head
becomes cool enough and it's business as
usual in fact though the beaks been
constantly replenished with hot water as
you can see the back part of the head
stays cool enough and soon you can see
the two birds are dunking pretty much
similar rates if you'd like to go back
and watch our original video with
Professor Phil Moriarty about these
dipping Birds I'll include a link on the
screen and in the description and thanks
to Professor Moriarty for helping me out
with this video and lastly also a big
thanks to Google's making and science
team if you'd like to see more films
with various youtubers they've supported
there are also links on the screen and
in the description
[Music]